the Mueller investigation into Trump
Russia collusion is taking serious fire
the Democrats are on the ropes after
their failed government shutdown and the
NFL makes a giant boo-boo leading up to
the Super Bowl I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
we have tons to get to today and
tomorrow I will be speaking at
University of Connecticut where of
course naturally the administration has
decided that I am a threat to public
safety and they've decided that the
general public will not be allowed to
attend it will be students only at
University of Connecticut this is the
second school in a row they've done this
over Berkeley they did this and now
they're doing at University of
Connecticut as well even though we
likely would have had thousands of
people who wanted to show up it's
getting very irritating for me we'll
discuss that a little bit later the uu
count by the way is actually
acknowledging that I am not the one who
promotes the violence they are saying
that they don't see me offending the
audience they don't see me coming there
to tick off the audience so at least
they're acknowledging that but doesn't
really change any of that we'll get to
all of that we will also get to these
bombshell text messages inside the FBI
regarding the Mueller investigation what
comes next on the government shutdown
and daca but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at my Patriot
supply so just a couple of weeks ago you
remember there was a false alarm in
Hawaii when everyone in the state of
Hawaii thought that they were going to
be nuked into the ground by North Korea
and if that got you thinking hey what
would happen if god forbid they were
actually disaster to that magnitude
first of all it's important to note just
because I'm not gonna get graphic every
just because the nuclear weapon would
fall on your city does not necessarily
mean that you will die right the fact is
that nuclear weapons actually do not
look like Terminator 2 they don't wipe
out entire cities instead nuclear
weapons affect a certain area if you're
living outside that area however you are
going to still be living without food
without water unless you go to my
Patriots supply this is not just true
obviously in the unlikely event of a
nuclear catastrophe it's also true for
natural disasters which have been
happening relatively frequently and you
see on the news all these people who
don't have food and they don't have
water that's why you need to go to my
Patriots apply they're the experts in
self-reliance get their 102 servings
survival food kit it lasts up to 25
years in storage for just $99 this
emergency food chips free to your house
call eight eight eight eight oh three 14
13 eight eight eight eight oh three 14
13 or go online to prepare with been
calm let's prepare with Ben's outcome to
order a kit or two the kits include
healthy flavorful food with variety of
breakfasts lunches and dinners people
the office of try them they say that
tastes like home cooking it's eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or go online to
prepare with Ben comm order a kit or two
keeps you safe for the next quarter
century so it's a one-time order these
kits include how
the flavorful food with a variety of
breakfasts lunches and dinners people
the office have tried them they say they
taste like home cooking check it out 888
803 1413 prepare with been calm ok so we
so we begin with today's we begin with
today's big news and that is these
bombshell text messages that are now
coming out from the FBI so the FBI has
turned over a bunch of text messages to
the Senate Judiciary Committee and the
and the House Judiciary Committee and
these text messages are not looking good
for the FBI so first off Bob Goodlatte
who is Republican from Virginia and
Devon Nunez Republican from California
as well as trey gowdy Republican of
South Carolina issued a statement on
text messages they received regarding
top FBI officials they requested all of
the backlog to text messages and here's
what they say quote this weekend we met
to discuss the text messages and
possible next steps in our oversight of
these agencies the contents of these
text messages between top FBI officials
are extremely troubling in terms of when
key decisions were made by the
Department of Justice and the FBI by
whom these decisions were made and the
evident bias exhibited by those in
charge of the investigation the omission
of text messages between December 2016
and May 2017 a critical gap encompassing
the FBI's Russia investigation is
equally concerning rather than clearing
up prior FBI and DOJ actions these
recently produced documents cause us to
further question the credibility and
objectivity of certain officials at the
FBI so as we mentioned yesterday on the
show there are a couple of big stories
that have come out of the FBI
the first is that there are these text
messages that were sent between members
of the FBI regarding the way the Mueller
investigation was run the second is that
hundreds of text messages apparently
have gone missing among thousands of
text messages that have gone missing
hundreds between Louisa page who was
working on Mueller investigation and her
paramour Peter is struck who's also
working on Mueller investigation was a
top counterintelligence guy yesterday on
Facebook live you should check it out in
our Facebook page we had the opportunity
to talk with representative Jim Jordan
Republican from Ohio who's overseeing a
lot of the stuff he's on the Oversight
Committee and and representative Jordan
was talking about the fact that they
need a second independent Council to
investigate the first independent
council because this investigation is is
compromised already I did ask him a
couple of the questions I've asked on
the show why doesn't the President of
the United States simply declassify the
FISA warrant that was taken out against
her page so we can find out whether any
the FBI was using bad Intel to target
President Obama's and Hillary Clinton's
political enemies he suggested that
perhaps Trump didn't want to politicize
the issue I find that unconvincing
nonetheless the fact is that there is an
in the the release the memo crew they
remember there was a memo last week that
we were talking about that supposedly
lays out all of the flaws in FISA
supposedly lays out all the problems
with the FBI this memo will be released
to the public in the next one to two
weeks we are now hearing so we'll have
more information at that point meanwhile
according to attorney general Jeff
Sessions this is reported over at
Gateway pundit which is sometimes
inaccurate but here it is apparently
accurate they have 50,000 text messages
that were exchanged between Peter struck
and his mistress Lisa page I don't think
that statistic is correct I think 50,000
text messages were missing some of those
were from a struck to page but foxy well
here's what Fox News says so let me get
this right I don't want to say something
is not true that's not true it says more
than 50 thousand texts were exchanged
between two FBI officials who have come
under fire for exchanging anti-trump
text messages during the 2016 election
attorney general jeff sessions revealed
monday the figure surfaced as lawmakers
have been pressing for answers about
after revelations that the FBI failed to
preserve five months of text between
Peter struck and Lisa page Jeff session
said we'll leave no stone unturned to
confirm with certainty why these text
messages are not now are not now
available to be produced and we will use
every technology available to determine
whether the missing messages are
recoverable from another source I have
to say the number of documents that have
gone missing whether it's Hillary
Clinton's email servers or whether it is
the FBI is suddenly losing tens of
thousands of texts pretty shocking stuff
the FBI servers included over 50,000
texts and apparently the FBI system
failed to retain text messages for
approximately five months between
December 14 2017 and May 17 2007 teen as
I suggested these dates are particularly
suspicious because May 17th 2017 is when
is literally the date that Robert
Mueller took over the investigation and
then apparently there's more so John
Ratcliffe who is a Republican from Texas
he said after reviewing the text
messages that he thinks there was a
quote unquote secret society of folks
within the DOJ and FBI working against a
Trump here's what the Federalist reports
quote trey Gowdy said the explanation
for the missing text may be fishier than
the
official explanation he says he saw
struck and page discussing getting rid
of texts in a printout of the messages
he and other members of Congress
received last week well lay that lay
aside this glaring five-month gap in
text that the world's premier agency
somehow missed Gowdy said what Johnny
and I saw today was a text about not
keeping texts we saw more manifest bias
against President Trump all the way
through the election into the transition
Ratcliffe said it is a strange
coincidence it is possible that these
messages that were missing perhaps it is
a strange coincidence and then Senator
Ron Johnson of Wisconsin he went even
further he said in a radio interview on
Tuesday with Jay Weber at WISN in
Milwaukee he read aloud a May 19th 2017
tax rates this would be two days after
they suddenly magically recovered texts
in this text apparently he wrote quote
there's two lisa page his mistress you
and i both know the odds are nothing
about whether this investigation is
going to turn up something and I thought
it was likely I'd be there no question I
hesitated in part because of my gut
sense and concerned there's no big there
there he said he didn't actually want to
join the Mueller investigation because
he didn't think there was anything
actually going on Johnson said I think
that's kind of jaw-dropping he said in
other words Peter struck who was the FBI
deputy assistant director of the
counterintelligence division the man who
had a plan to do something because he
just couldn't abide Donald Trump being
president he's saying that his gut sense
that there's no big there there when it
comes to the Mueller Special Counsel
investigation now I will say that it
does seem like there's a conflict
between this text and the implication
that struck was basically ginning up a
fake investigation in order to get Trump
right suggests there was something else
going on inside the FBI but not the
Trump collusion investigation not the
Mueller investigation because if indeed
struck was texting his paramour Lisa
page and suggesting hey Lisa
there's nothing here and I don't want to
join the investigation about Trump
Russia collusion because I don't think
there's anything there then that does
pose a different point of view than the
suggestion that he was trying to craft
out of whole cloth this narrative that
Trump was colluding with Russia and then
shoved that down the throats of people
over at the FBI in other words there's a
lot of there's a lot of confusion going
on here they're certainly gonna have to
have struck texts of testify they're
gonna have to have Lisa page testify I
do find it highly suspicious that the
FBI is saying these messages just went
missing again if you are working for the
government and messages just go missing
that is that is really suspicious you're
not allowed to delete government
messages this way I did get a note
away from somebody who's an expert on
cybersecurity who said that it's very
unlikely these messages are gone forever
they said the FBI is required to conform
to NIS TSP 834 contingency planning
guide for federal information systems
which requires multiple layers of
redundancy and backup these federal
continuity and contingency guidelines
are designed to assure that systems and
data survive multiple natural disasters
and 911 types of events it is not
possible for a singular glitch to cause
the data to be lost that means that if
the data were lost then there'd have to
be some sort of organized effort is the
is the suggestion here so if that is
indeed the case then there's a lot more
than meets the eye here in any case all
of this is disturbing
all of it requires investigation I'm not
going to buy into the complete
Republican narrative that the that this
was all set up from the very beginning
and that it was based on bad Intel him
that it was created out of whole cloth
by Hillary Clinton Barack Obama in order
to get Donald Trump I don't know what
the evidence is there for that I will
say however that something smells fishy
here with the missing text and with the
text about a secret society and all of
the rest of this it's all it's all
confusing and it requires a lot of
exploitation okay so in just a second I
want to talk about the the fallout from
the government shutdown that failed for
Democrats first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at blue apron so
everybody in the office is now using
blue apron the reason is not only is it
healthier not only is it faster you
don't have to go out over to a
restaurant not only is it more expensive
but it's also more fun you get to cook
with your family in your home I mean you
can it's it's short rib burgers with a
hoppy cheddar sauce on a pretzel bun
seared steaks and thyme pan sauce is
natural potatoes you're cooking like a
gourmet and you don't even have to know
how to cook really my blue apron is the
number one fresh ingredient when recipe
delivery service in the country their
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone they
offer three plans the two-person meal
plan meals that serve two people and you
choose from eight new recipes per week
with the choice to receive two the two
or three recipes any week the family
meal plan these are meals that serve
four people and you can choose from four
new recipes per week with the choice to
receive either two three or four recipes
in any given week and then there's the
wine plan as well six bottles of wine
from renowned wine makers delivered
monthly blue apron is treating my my
listeners right now to $30 off your
first order if you visit blue apron comm
slash apparel blue apron comm slash
Craig at 30 bucks off your first order
and right now for eight weeks they're
teaming up with hole 30 to bring you
delicious recipe
their menu features to hold 30 approved
recipes every week like seared steaks in
warm lemon salsa verde with roasted
broccoli and sweet potato chicken and
kale orange salad with spicy tahini
dressing I mean this stuff all sounds
just a magnificent again they send the
packs to your house and if it's and if
the the ingredients are not good then
they will make it good for you right
it's blue apron calm slash capiro a
better way to cook and when you use that
slash up hero again you get $30 off your
first order
$30 off your first order it's a lot of
variety by the way the menu changes
every week based on what's in season
it's designed by their in-house keulen
era team that for 12 new recipes per
week and customers can pick two three or
four based on what best fits their
schedule they're only sending non GMO
ingredients meat with no added hormones
so I mean it's all great stuff again
blue aprons calm Shapiro's use that
slash apparel and get $30 off with free
shipping I mean I have pictures of the
meals here and they just look
spectacular so check it out blue apron
die commies that slash up heroes they
know that we sent you okay so meanwhile
well there's all this fallout
surrounding the Muller investigation
there's also fallout surrounding the
Democrats completely blowing it on the
government shutdown one of the things
that is absolutely hilarious is joy Reid
over at MSNBC said that the government
shutdown was actually not a loss for
Democrats
she is incorrect it is in fact a very
large loss for Democrats they got
nothing in return and looked like
cowards they basically they they look
like brave Sir Robin ran away they stood
there and they said that they were going
to to fight to the end the end lasted
approximately 69 hours and then out they
were they were done so Chuck Schumer
tried to pretend that he had won a big
victory yesterday when he announced the
end of the government shutdown needless
to say this was untrue the Republican
leader and I have come to an arrangement
we will vote today to reopen the
government to continue notion
negotiating a global agreement with the
commitment that if an agreement isn't
reached by February the 8th the Senate
will immediately proceed to
consideration of legislation dealing
with daca ok we'll only one problem the
White House has immediately announced
that they are not going to push for any
of the any of the proposals that the
Democrats would want here so for example
White House spokesperson holds a Hogan
Gidley he said that Graham's urban which
is the bill that Schumer wants this is
the bill that will give
two billion dollars for the border wall
but nothing else in exchange for keeping
800,000 dreamers and their parents here
the White House spokesperson said that's
not on the table so while Chuck Schumer
is saying we want a big victory here the
answer is no they really did in this
clip six senator Graham and Senator
Durbin were completely dishonest when
they brought the plan to the president
it did not do anything to address chain
migration in fact it blew it up and made
it bigger
it gave basically amnesty those two have
been in lockstep on immigration for
decades they want open borders they want
amnesty that's what Lindsey Graham is
about I'm from South Carolina I've known
the man for a long time and it's fine he
can take that position but to pretend
he's anything other than someone who
wants open borders in amnesty it's just
disingenuous so the White House is
taking a very strong stance at least
publicly on immigration which means the
Democrats gained nothing they didn't
even gain any sort of and anything here
in the bargain right debbie Wasserman
Schultz was asked about this the former
head of the DNC she was asked by Brianna
Keller on on CNN what exactly did you
gain through all of this and and debbie
Wasserman Schultz head I mean nothing
there's literally nothing what one thing
did he get you know from Republicans to
justify shutting down the government in
the first place so so the one thing I
would say that he did get is the
potential for momentum because if and
I'm certainly hopeful that then maybe a
one-story position I'm still hung up
that when I know Americans are listening
and they heard you say it's
reverberating potential for momentum and
they're thinking for momentum was that
really worth shutting the government
down for what tential for something I
will tell you that Republicans should be
asking themselves that question because
they shut the government down okay again
of both ways either you shut the
government down relation at the
government down it's not that they shut
the government down and we gained
momentum by them shutting the government
down you shut the government down and
then you admitted you shut the
government down and Chuck Schumer
admitted you shut the government down I
do love that this is like emanations
from penumbra's in in terms of
meaningless phrases potential for
momentum is pretty spectacular you know
it has potential for momentum this cup
sitting right here it has potential for
momentum but in order for it to have
momentum I actually have to generate
some force into the cup right this is
the thing about momentum it has to be
generated by a certain amount of force
okay initially momentum doesn't just
happen this is called inertia potential
for momentum is literally any object
this microphone has potential for
momentum if I would take it and throw it
right now potential for momentum it
means nothing okay that the it's
literally a meaningless phrase potential
for momentum so this is what they gain
other Democrats are ripping Chuck Shumer
up and down there is a gap that is
opening wide inside the Democratic Party
it's kind of fascinating it's reflective
of the same gap that opened inside the
Republican Party in 2013 after the
government shutdown there there are a
lot of people in the Republican side who
said you're not fighting Barack Obama
hard enough you need to shut down the
government you need to stop the funding
of Obamacare because once it's in place
it's gonna be very difficult for us ever
to to remove it and there is a gap that
opened up this is really where I think a
lot of the the anger at Mitch McConnell
started was the feeling that that he was
not fighting hard enough on all of these
particular matters and what that led to
was such discontent in the Republican
Party that Donald Trump was able to
waltz through the front door and simply
take over the party you're seeing the
same thing in the Democratic Party
there's a fight now between the
so-called establishment wing of the
Democratic Party led by Chuck Schumer
and the progressive wing of the
Democratic Party all the people who are
run in 2020 are now basically doing what
Ted Cruz did in 2013 right Cruz wanted
to run for president in 2016 and so he
shut down the government and I like
senator Cruz I don't think that it was
completely a political ploy by Cruz I
think that he felt he was doing what he
had to do but there's no question that
he had his eye on the presidential race
in 2016 the Democrats are doing the same
thing now now they're all posturing by
saying were the ones who really stood
tough Chuck Schumer didn't stand tough
all the people in the Senate who want to
run for president are being very clear
about what they want to do here Chris
Coons from Delaware he basically was
trying to encourage all these 2020
contenders guys simmer now shut up like
Ken what can we actually govern well
here are you guys just gonna run for
president what appeals to our base for
some primary several years from now is
not what I'm worried about what I'm
worried about is how do we solve real
problems and my gut is that at the end
of the day that's what people are
looking for in a next national leader as
well so for my colleagues who are hoping
that they might be on the ticket in 2020
I don't think simply moving further and
further to the left is the best way to
accomplish that I think showing we can
solve big problems is the way to
encourage people to believe that
Democrats belong in control of the
Congress
and back in the white house but this is
what's so fascinating is that the the
Democrats who want to win are now
opposed to the Democrats who are radical
right well we're seeing now is that the
Democrats are moving farther and further
to the left this is what's amazing is it
the recommend studying since 2010
Republicans have been stagnant the
Democratic Party however continues to
move further and further to the left and
Trump has prompted them to move even
further to the left because their hatred
of Trump means knee-jerk opposition to
anything he does including funding
things like the children's health
insurance program by the way funny to
note remember one like two days ago
Jimmy Kimmel was complaining that the
Republicans wouldn't fund chip oh the
Republicans are holding chip hostage oh
the Republicans won't fund the
children's health insurance program
oh they're evil oh they're terrible the
Republicans just funded chip for another
six years did Jimmy Kimmel have anything
to say about that last night on his show
no no there's a giant shock because he's
taking all of his cues from Chuck
Schumer but again the gap in the
Democratic Party is open and widening
Nancy Pelosi was trying to prevent it
from widening still further she came out
yesterday and she said I think that it
was a mistake for us not to continue the
government shutdown but then she tried
to spend this all as Trump small they're
gonna try and go back to the well and
use Trump as their unifying force what I
think the main obstacle is if I may is
this there's a dark cloud hanging over
the capital and that dark cloud is the
Trump tax scam that took nearly two
trillion dollars and and added it to the
deficit when you take the cost and the
and the interest on the debt two
trillion dollars so therefore the impact
on on members only Republican side
voting for more domestic investments is
diminished Oh like hit like Democrats
care at all about deficits come on
when's the last time Democrats gave to
dams about a deficit that's that's
ridiculous but you know she's trying to
shift blame off of Schumer as well she
should the only person who's honest
about this that I saw completely honest
was luis Gutierrez the Democrat from
Illinois who is very hardcore and
immigration and who was perfectly
willing to shut down the government over
all of this because this is his lead
issue he says listen my Democratic
colleagues they blink they lost
I think they cave they blinked they're
you know most of my Democrats are
good at articulating their values and
and how enthusiastically they support
their values sometimes they're not as
strong and so she is defending them in
the legislative process so there we are
the Democrats I think are going to be
slugging this one out for at least a
little while to come yeah if they win
the house in in 2018 then it is possible
that all of this comes to an end victory
tends to bring parties together loss
tends to divide parties this is
obviously the case with the Democrats
who run literally zero branches of
government at this point one of the
things that's been fascinating is that
not only on Republicans gaining in the
polls but if you look at the way that
the districts run Democrats have a bit
of an uphill run a lot of the districts
have become a lot more partisan and
polarized so Democrats would basically
have to have a wave in order to take
over the house I've been suggesting for
a while I think they probably will take
over the house but I don't think that
it's gonna be any surefire bet
especially the way the Democrats are
blowing it this government shutdown does
not help them it gives the impression
that they're not competent and the truth
is they aren't they decided to blackmail
the Republicans they put a gun to their
own head and decide to blackmail the
Republicans it was the scene from
Blazing Saddles where where the black
sheriff puts the gun to his own head and
says and they're trying to hang him and
he says don't hang me they put the gun
to his own head he says don't hang me or
the bleep gets it right and that's how
they go no no don't do it don't do it
the Democrats thought that strategy was
actually going to work here that
strategy obviously did not work here
they blink they look bad and now we're
running up on February 8th there's gonna
be another government shutdown but
Democrats have no leverage here and that
brings up the question as to what comes
next because the Republicans have
basically said we're gonna try and
handle daca before February 8th that day
is quickly approaching it's already
January 23rd so that means that were
basically two weeks out but we'll get to
that in just a second first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at
filter by so the holidays might be over
but the winter is in full swing and that
means that you're spending a lot more
time indoors
well according to studies the air
indoors contains up to 100 times more
pollution than the air outside which can
cause illness allergies unnecessary wear
and tear on your HVAC system or even the
premature replacement of the entire
system if you don't replace it your
filters that's why you need filter by
they carry over 600 different filter
sizes including custom options all
shipped free within 24 hours they're
manufactured right here in the United
States we've used it at our house it's
the easiest thing in the world you just
go on your side on their site and you
choose which
you want and not only that they also
offer in automatic programs there's auto
delivery so every time every few months
they send you the the air filters that
you need you never have to think about
it again you never have to oh well I
wouldn't last time I change the filter I
guess must have been two years ago
that's not gonna happen to you anymore
they offer a multitude of whom ME RV
options all the way up to hospital grade
so you'll be removing dangerous pollen
mold dust other allergy aggravating
pollution while maximizing the
efficiency of your system and right now
you save five percent when you set up
auto delivery so you never need to think
about those air filters again it's
filter by comm filter bu why coming and
that's filter by comm and you save five
percent when you set up auto delivery so
you never need to think about those air
filters again filter bu why.com filter
by comm all right so what comes next on
data that of course is the next step the
Democrats suggest that they have the
potential for momentum that they are
finally going to be moving forward and
the the answer is not so much because I
mentioned the White House is making
clear that they don't want to cave to
Democrats and they honestly have no
interesting having two Democrats let's
play this out let's say no deal gets
done well get to February 8th the
Democrats are not going to shut down the
government again so we'll get another
funding bill it won't include daca and
then we'll get to March and the
Democrats by the way have no interest in
actually saving Trump from having to
back down but Trump could easily just
say listen we're not gonna fix Jaca
right we're not gonna be issuing any new
any new deck of permits but we're also
not going to start deporting people
right we're just gonna let people stay
here we'll go after the the criminal
illegal aliens first if he says that
then nothing really happens is the
urgency here this is the thing about all
of us that makes no sense the urgency
here is a little bit overblown by the
President of the United States can just
continue to wait daca the same way that
the the former president of the United
States has right there the the the fact
that the fact that Jack guy is coming to
an end on March 8 doesn't mean that mass
and that massive deportations are about
to happen the deadline just means that
they're not gonna be issuing any more
new papers for people who have been
trying to who've been trying to get
papers to stay in the country
permanently
sorry - a March 5th is the date that
they're looking at actually right so the
idea that that the world ends on March
5th unless they come to some sort of
deal obviously is not true right
obviously it's just not
so that means that there's not a lot of
pressure on Trump to come to a deal and
it's not a lot of pressure on Democrats
to come to the deal right here's what we
know right there the March 5th deadline
ends protections for young undocumented
immigrants if Congress fails to do
anything but the Homeland Security
Secretary is already saying that they're
not gonna do anything about this but the
White House is sort of making hints
because they have to right they're
trying to push Democrats into making a
deal but Sarah Huckabee Sanders said
that you know maybe they'll start
supporting three murders probably not
said we haven't determined that we're
hopeful we don't have to do that
we don't have to get there we'd like
Democrats to get serious about solving
problems the suggestion being that if we
reach this deadline and nothing happens
then Trump could just say you know what
a little more time for negotiation I'm
not gonna deport people that's the most
likely outcome of all of this right not
that he starts mass deportations the way
that Ann Coulter would like but then he
actually doesn't do any of that so both
sides have an interest in reaching a
deal but both sides also have an
interest in not reaching a deal which
means that this will probably drag on
beyond the deadline the the idea of a
quick deadline by February 8th is not
gonna happen and the proof is in the
pudding
Chuck Schumer is already taken off the
table offers that he had already made
right so Chuck Schumer is taking his big
spending boost for the border wall off
the table according to Politico this
happened in the last few minutes the
Senate Minority Leader through an aide
informed the White House on Monday he
was retracting the offer he made last
week to give Trump well north of 1.6
billion dollars in wall funding Trump
had asked for this year according to two
Democrats now they say Trump will simply
not get a better deal than that on his
signature campaign promise
so Schumer offered a large increase in
border while spending as a condition for
a broader deal to help dreamers after
that offer was rebuffed prompting the
shutdown the president has missed the
opportunity to get the wall said one
Democratic aid the Senator Jeff Flake
had already considered using the promise
of border wall funding totaling more
than 1.6 billion dollars in order to
lure more conservative votes a dreamer
plan written by a bipartisan group of
six senators had included Trump's 1.6
billion dollar request as part of a
broader 2.7 billion dollar border
security package but the White House had
already rejected that deal so basically
Schumer is withdrawing from a deal at
the White House was never going to make
so the Democrats have no interest in
coming to the table and offering
anything they would like to see mass
deportations here's the dirty little
secret Democrats want Trump to do a mass
deportation so they can get all the
headlines about how mean and cruel
Republicans are leading up
to the midterms and Republicans have no
interest in surrendering on daca because
they want to get their base out for the
midterms so my prediction no deal
happens here so all the talk about how
you know we have to reach a deal we have
to reach a deal it's not gonna happen
Tim Kaine senator from from Virginia
former vice presidential candidate he
said we all want a permanent fix right
everyone Democrats Republicans we all
want a permanent fix they're lying
none of them do all of us in the room
felt the same way so we we're you know
sitting around in Susan's office again
and again and then we're dispatching and
going talking to the leaders and then
coming back and doing the same thing
shuttle diplomacy so we do have a strong
degree of trust in each other that we
want this outcome of opening the
government and finding a permanent
protection for dreamers everybody in
that room said we got to find permanent
protection for dreamers and that's
really important um the idea that
they're going to actually move forward
with something again I find highly
unlikely they don't have the votes for
it in the Senate Democrats are saying to
trump you can't just yell about what you
want but the truth is that they
basically can't ari Melbourne at MSNBC
was trying to pressure Trump obviously
this is not going to work mr. president
here's the deal right now you set a
deadline for when you'd start deporting
children unless Congress acted then you
said you had a deal with Congress then
you blew up that deal if you make a deal
and don't stick to it long enough to
sign it you will push people to find
other ways to try to force your hand and
since this is a democracy not a
dictatorship or a scripted reality show
you won't always have the final say by
yourself even when you have the top job
you don't get to skip the hard part
because you only run a co-equal branch
of government which of course was
recently shut down
you can't just yell what you want or go
home
well actually it's exactly what he can
do and he just did it and the Democrats
caved
so the fact is that's exactly what he
will do and again I think the chances of
reaching a deal here when Democrats are
not bending at all is extraordinarily
low right here is Senator mazie Hirono
from Hawaii she said listen the funding
for the wall is off the table we're not
gonna do that so he's saying Melbourne
is saying Trump can't just shout what he
wants and then go home but that's
exactly what Democrats are doing
Democrats are shouting what they want
and then going home you almost
interrupted me when I was talking about
Senator Schumer
giving the money for the wall to the
president is that as it has that changed
oh of course
the wall is no longer something that you
know the Chuck Shumer who was willing to
put the wall on the tape if we got a
full dacha and full of dreamers and
that's not happening so that's off the
table what if you it's what if there's
an offer for dacha but that has to go
back on the table is the wall funding
gonna go back on the table at some point
I think we're going to have a
full-throated debate Dhaka and possibly
on a lot of other aspects of
comprehensive immigration reform and I
know where I'm coming from that we need
to keep our focus on the urgency of
taking care of the daca dreamers and
also comprehensive immigration reform
that maintains family unity they're just
gonna muddle through this yeah they're
just gonna muddle through here's the
reality Republicans would like to make a
deal on daca they would they'd like to
make a deal that also includes border
security Democrats don't want any deal
that ends illegal immigration they don't
they want another wave of illegal
immigrants coming through and that's
because for both humanitarian reasons
and also because they believe that these
are all future Democratic voters they
would like the border to remain open
because this is a simple deal when you
ask the common American just the normal
American what do you want on immigration
the monaural American by the polls it
shows that the vast majority of
Americans would like to see some sort of
legal status for the dreamers it also
shows the vast majority of Americans
would like to see an increased border
security presence as well as and ends
the diversity Visa Lottery and chain
migration right there is a deal on the
table Democrats don't want that deal so
there will be no deal I think that
there's a good shot that Republicans
should actually try and cut that deal
themselves and just and just invoke the
nuclear option if they have to in order
to do it because otherwise Democrats are
gonna continue using this as a club to
be it Republicans with over and over and
over again this issues not gonna get
resolved because no one has an interest
in watching this issue gets resolved
unfortunately even though they're all
lying about it to you okay
so I want to talk a little bit about the
schoolmarm in media as well as the NFL
blowing itself up right before the Super
Bowl in just the most foolish possible
fashion but for that you're gonna have
to go over to Daley we're calm and
subscribe for $99 for $9.99 dollars
$9.99 a month $9.99 a month you get your
subscription to daily wire means you get
to be part of our show watch the rest of
it live watch Michael moe
show live watch Andrew Clavin show live
yet to be part of our mailbag here on
Fridays it also means that when you get
your annual subscription for $99 a year
you get this the greatest in all
beverage vessels left dist tears hot or
cold mug this thing has been filled to
overflowing lately and is renewed every
single day apparently by Cory Booker
specifically so check out your leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr when you get
the annual subscription if you want to
listen later iTunes SoundCloud Google
Play stitcher subscribe to our channel
over at YouTube as well we have plenty
of new videos coming out on a daily
basis check all of that out we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so with all of this happening now
president Trump's approval rating has
continued to be in the dumps which just
shows you that his personal toxicity
that does not it does not work well for
him even though a lot of his base may
like it the reason I say this is because
there's a poll out today that shows
Trump matched up against various
Democrats and it does not look
particularly good for president from now
do these polls mean anything not
particularly because in the end you end
up running against a candidate you know
and when you run against Ted Kennedy you
drag them down in the mud at this time
in 2015 or 2013 rather you were looking
at Donald Trump wasn't even on the polls
right now he's the president of United
States but if you look at the polls
right now Joe Biden in 57% Trump at 40
ye but Sanders at 55 Trump at 42 and
Oprah Winfrey at 51 Trump 42 that last
one is the most fascinating of the three
but it suggested that the Democratic
upswell for Oprah Winfrey that Oprah
Winfrey is gonna be the next candidate
of the future she's barely breaking 50%
Joe Biden of course is cleaning the
floor with Trump that makes sense he's
an established politician he's also
somebody with with a blue blue collar
appeal apparently and and Bernie Sanders
of course is highly popular until he
actually has to face up with Trump this
doesn't mean of course that Trump would
actually lose to these people take all
of those statistics with a grain of salt
but the fact is that Trump's personal
toxicity is driving down numbers for
president Trump and for Republicans what
is what is providing a lift for Trump
and for Republicans is the continued
media malfeasance so the fact is the
economy right now is very good on
foreign policy the situation is looking
a lot better than anyone thought it
would a year ago with Isis in full-scale
retreat Russia basically boxed in and
North Korea for all of the talk about it
is is still in relatively contained
position even though they continue to
fire missiles they have no intention of
going to war with anyone as far as I can
tell the media however continued to lie
to people and the more the media do this
the media basically become Hollywood
right Hollywood in the media who
basically be they they've merged
whatever the media say whenever they
offer their opinion whenever they get
involved in the kind of schoolmarm of
President Trump people react badly to
that Chris Cuomo was responsible for it
yesterday he had on Kellyanne Conway and
who's slapping Kellyanne Conway for
defending president Trump's tweets
during the women's March
was marched from tweeted out that he was
happy that these women were marching and
also by the way the economy is great
which seems like a fine tweet to me but
here's chris cuomo going after Kellyanne
Conway what are you talking about I
think the people who were marching on
Saturday would disagree the women's
March the one where the president was
tweeting that all the people are out
there marching to say how great he's
done no no how great the economy is we
have the lowest unemployment rate for
women in seven no that's not why they
were marching it's not insulting to all
those women out there who are looking
for leadership and looking for someone
to get behind them and the city makes a
joke out of their March
it's no joke that the women's
unemployment rate is the lowest in 17
years it is no joke that over a half a
million new women enter the workforce in
his watch and it's no joke that they
don't get equal pay and women like you
have been forced to do it twice as hard
as men to get to the same place
mansplain as so Chris Cuomo demands
splitting a Kellyanne Conway about the
fake gender gap which is just
entertaining as all hell and then people
wonder why Trump continues to win when
he just says that the economy is good
and Chris Cuomo loses his ever-loving
mind
speaking of media malfeasance so the NFL
has seen its ratings to climb
dramatically this year I mean they said
they've had a serious hit in terms of
their of their public image people don't
like the NFL nearly as much as they used
to I think there are a couple of things
behind that one is every time somebody
gets hit in the head we immediately
think this guy is going to suffer
serious brain damage future in the
future and that's that's a problem but
beyond that it did not help the NFL that
their entire image has now been
plastered with the people kneeling from
the national anthem it got worse okay
then the American and veterans group
this American veterans group AMVETS
tried to take out an ad for the Super
Bowl and that ad was it was an ad
featuring servicemembers saluting Old
Glory as well as their response to the
take any message right so here is what
the ad looks like you can actually is
this video it's just it's just a graphic
it's just a graphic so what you can see
is is these these soldiers standing with
the flag and then it just says make a
$20 tax-deductible donation and help us
help veterans by texting veterans two
four four four nine nine nine
and then it's just his hashtag please
stand which is seeming seems to be
respectful to me so they wanted to take
out that ad instead the the NFL said no
so the AMVETS a national commander
Marian Polk said freedom of speech works
both ways to respect the rights of those
who choose to protest as these rights
are precisely what our members have
fought and in many case died for
but imposing corporate censorship to
deny that same right to those veterans
who have secured it for us all is
reprehensible and totally beyond the
pale so this was supposed to be a 30,000
dollar ad the apparently the NFL vice
president of communications told the
army Times that the league asked them to
change the message to please stand for
our veterans but the group was unable to
make changes in time for the deadline
instead the NFL is running a similar ad
apparently from the Veterans of Foreign
Wars with the message we stand for
veterans the NFL has for spent two years
allowing players to sit kneel raise a
fist perform other symbolic acts during
the performance of the star-spangled
banner and it's not true by the way the
Superbowl gets rid of politically
charged as they had a couple of them let
just last year of course man I remember
that that they did in an audio ad we
made fun of it on the show titled
daughter all about how your daughter is
gonna be discriminated against but at
least she'll be able to drive an Audi I
remember that from last year and then
there are a couple of ads last year
having to do with the illegal
immigration also in the middle of the
election cycle so rejecting an ad that
says please stand because they want to
say stand for veterans I don't
understand why you can't have an ad that
just to stand for the flag or stand for
the anthem like it's vague it says
please stand
obviously it's referring to the anthem
and the flag the reason you stand for
the vets is because the vets stand for
the flag and for the anthem these things
are related but this just demonstrates
how the people in the media
misunderstand the people they are
catering to the people who actually
watch the NFL stand for the flag and
there's a reason that President Trump
when he attended the college football
championship game was actually cheered
by the crowd the fact is that people who
watch football are more likely to be in
favor of standing for the flag than the
average member of the population people
watch football skew male excuse rural
instead of urban and the fact is and I'm
not talking about black versus white I'm
just talking about population centers on
the coast particularly versus the middle
of the country the ratings are higher in
the middle of the country from what I
understand all of this being the case
it is absolute foolishness for the NFL
to continue alienating its own viewing
population but this is what Hollywood
tends to do remember the NFL's part of
the entertainment complex and the
entertainment complex is mostly
interested in pleasing people who live
inside the entertainment complex they
don't want to tick off their own players
by running this ad so which I would
suggest better to have the the better to
have the audience tick off the players
and have the players tick off the
audience I mean then the NFL's got
enough hits that it's taking right now
that the last thing that it needs is to
harm itself further by rejecting ads
from from veterans that are simply
saying stand for the flag well what
absolute silliness ok so I want to do a
couple things I like and then some
things I hate and then we will
deconstruct the culture a little bit so
let's just jump right into things I like
so things I like will begin with
dune so been doing a little bit of
sci-fi and fantasy this week I did
Brandon Sanderson yesterday this of
course one of the great classics of the
sci-fi genre dune by Frank Herbert it is
a very very good book it really reads
the movie is awful the original movie of
dune I believe they're making a new
version aren't they I think they're
doing a new version the whole premise of
dune if I recall it's been a year since
I've read it but the whole premise of
dune is that there's a planet that
basically has no water on it and and
there is a it's a desert planet and it's
the only source of a particular spice
and so the entire commerce of the planet
runs off this particular spice and it's
all about you know the enslavement of
particular populations and rebellions
and it's in declining empires it's
really interesting it's a really
fascinating book and it is a
world-building book right is it is a
book that is that is built on the it's a
it's a book that is built on the
building of an entire galaxy essentially
so it's it's worth rating I wish I
remembered more about it I could
recommend it more highly but it is worth
checking out okay other things that I
like so megan kelly did something that's
just wonderful so Megan I think at NBC
News
I like Megan I'm friendly with Megan I
think that her best attribute as a as a
journalist as an interviewer is that she
is willing to take no guff from anyone I
wish she would do that more an NBC
whenever she doesn't on NBC it's really
good when she does the sort of soft talk
we're gonna talk about what we're doing
with her name
today's stuff I don't think that's Megan
her best I think Megan and her best is
this right Megan really is great at this
so she had Jane Fonda on the show and
Jane and she asked Jane Fonda about
plastic surgery which again in a normal
interview I don't see the problem with
that like I think it's realistic to ask
a woman of Jane Fonda's age how she
looks like that and what she would do to
recommend plastic surgery would you
recommend it would she not Jane Fonda
apparently got very offended by the so
megyn kelly just took her to the
woodshed it's brutal look I gave her the
chance to empower other women young and
old on a subject which she purports to
know well and she rejected it that's
okay but I have no regrets about that
question nor am i in the market for a
lesson from Jane Fonda on what is and is
not appropriate after all this is a
woman whose name is synonymous with
outrage
look at her treatment of our military
during the Vietnam War many of our
veterans attempted to shame American
troops she posed on an anti-aircraft gun
used to shoot down our American pilots
she called our POWs hypocrites and liars
and referred to their torture as
understandable even she had to apologize
years later for that gun picture but not
for the rest of it by the way she still
says she is not proud of America okay
boom so I think the message here is do
not cross megyn kelly when it comes to
plastic surgery questions because I
worry she basically just takes a brick
out of her back pocket and clocks Jane
Fonda across that it's been a long time
coming the fact that Jane Fonda has been
a well accepted part of Hollywood for
decades after doing what she did during
the Vietnam War is insane and without
apology is even more insane so the
that's pretty amazing okay one more
thing that I like this is an amazing
video of a 20 week old baby in utero and
again one of the reasons that the
pro-life movement is making so much so
much hay right now is because we can
actually see inside the womb right and
you couldn't see inside the womb then
you could pretend that that wasn't a
baby in there now they can see inside
the womb better and better these days it
is obvious that that is of course a
child that you're killing a child when
you decide to quote-unquote abort I mean
if you can't see this that's a baby
right there there's no way to look at
that and not saying it's a baby it's a
baby and the woman obviously it's a
fully-formed baby in the womb at 20
weeks
by the way the idea that that humanity
is only based on what we can recognize
physically is also silly but there's a
reason that Planned Parenthood truly
objects to 40 ultrasounds and 3d
ultrasounds the idea is that they have
they they hate the idea that people are
actually going to be forced to look at
the child that they're going to kill I
mean it's an amazing imagery of that
imagery just incredible is so that's
amazing stuff okay time for a couple of
things that I hate let's do that they
don't really do one thing I hate today
so that is morning Joe decided to cut an
anthem for the women's March so all of
the virtue signaling about the women's
March is just ridiculous all the way
through morning Joe used to be a
quote-unquote fair and balanced show
right where Joe Scarborough is the
Republican and Mika Brzezinski was the
Democrat and now they're married to each
other which is weird dynamic but in any
case here was Joe Scarborough and Mika
Brzezinski talking about how they had
cut an anthem for the women's March
because we all have to pretend that the
women's March is some grand special
thing when in reality women literally
have no idea why they're marching
they're going out there because it's
called the women's March there's a very
funny video going around online where a
lot of women were being asked what are
you marching for and some of them have
the platitudinous answers about equal
pay but some of them just say we're
marching for women and they don't
actually know what they're marching
about anyway here is the the anthem
being played by by by Joe Scarborough we
go to break with some of the powerful
images from over the weekend as millions
of Americans gathered in cities and
streets across the nation for the 2018
women's March
[Music]
once any life you may get the chance to
stand
comes to call them at a president is
hearing it just over I'm holding up your
hand you're not setting against tanks
when you stand against Rome
[Music]
we're not stopping
where's I deep within your heart
that change the outcome have somebody
like this in the white house
I mean just the propaganda and the
propaganda purely about Trump right the
whole the whole song is just and they're
just showing pictures of Trump and how
terrible Trump is right as it I mean the
lyrics from once in your life you may
get a chance to stand against a column
of Tanks like Trump is a column of Tanks
what in the world yeah now MSNBC then
they're maybe just a little bit of bias
there okay time for a quick
deconstruction of the culture so one of
the things that came up during the
women's March apparently there are some
lyrics to a song called bodek yellow
which I've never heard of these things
so that's why I analyzed them for you
because if I haven't heard of them I
assume that you haven't either
maybe I'm just uninformed in any case
they're a bunch of they're a bunch of
pictures from the women's March that
that have people holding up Bo dak
yellow lyrics little bleeps you can't f
with me right so that's a picture of one
there's shoes stomping on trump's head
then there's another one of shoes
stomping on Pence's head
bloody moves and then it's a picture of
I don't know is that supposed to be a
period I'm confused as to what this is
supposed to be in any case these lyrics
have apparently become a thing now so
let's look a little bit at the video for
Bo dak yellow and explain why this has
become a phenomenon
[Music]
okay one of the things that I do like
about this video is that she's literally
riding a camel in the middle of the
Arabian desert presumably that is not a
very empowered place just noting that's
not that's not a place where strippers
make lots of money in Saudi Arabia right
but in any case
boudic yellows I guess her cardi B is is
the name of this human and cardi B began
stripping at the age of 19 she still
says the strip club is her favorite
place for dates and then she was on Love
& Hip Hop in New York and then she and
then she does all of the sort of shock
tactics that you expect from from your
normal rapper but here's what the lyrics
actually saying this is supposed to be
this is supposed to be empowering for
women okay this is if this is
empowerment for women let me suggest
that women need to to think more of
themselves because this seems rather
degrading actually she says let's find
out and see cardi B you know where I'm
at you know where I be you and the club
just a party I'm there I get paid a fee
I'd be in and out then Bank so much I
know they're tired of me but honestly I
don't give a bleep about who ain't fond
of me drop two mixtapes in six months
what bleep working as hard as me so she
hasn't work ethics that's that's good
she's I don't bother with these hoes
don't let these hoes bother me they say
pictures they say goals B I'm who they
trying to be look I might just chill in
some babe I might just chill with your
boo I might just feel on your babe my
bleep feel like a lake he want to swim
with his face so now it seems like she's
getting aggressive with other women so
I'm missing the part where this is all
female solidarity when she's talking
about how she's competing with other
women to take their men and also she
works harder than you but it's so
empowered it's just so all of this is so
empowered I mean and she by the way she
uses language that if a man used this
language it would be considered sexist
races if you'e bleep you get popped
bleep being a word for the female
anatomy if men use the word that way
they are considered sexist if a woman
like like cardi B
the word than its empowerment I my
bleep is glitter as gold I don't know
why again I guess if you're obsessed
with your own genitalia then this is
empowering to you but I guess the what
I'm not sure what else to expect from a
woman's March that thinks it's
empowerment to actually wear a hat on
your head that is supposedly named after
a vagina and the so just well done women
all over the United States we're really
empowering themselves by by glorifying
stripping and glorifying cheating and
glorifying stepping on other women
because that's what you can do just
really really good female solidarity
stuff there okay so we will be back here
tomorrow with much more we will be
broadcasting from the great state of
Connecticut so we will see you then I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and arrow
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018